Hello,
every body,
just before we get started
into this one today,
I do want to say that a
lot of Japanese words,
if I scrub the pronunciations,
I did my best.
Have a good at me in the comments
below if you want that spot there for
me and motive muscle sheet
was the greatest swordsman
you rather come out of a
nation of great swordsman and
that would of course in Japan.
His story which has become the basis for
countless flying swords and an oriental
movies is one of raw courage,
unbridled ambition,
and unparalleled mindfulness
in one on one combat.
He defeated 16 opponents,
yet his greatest legacy is a seminal work.
The book of five rings,
which is still poor,
dover by military
tacticians and mindfulness,
enthusiastic for 150 years
after it was written.
In this week's biographics,
we reveal the man that was Masashi
there as much uncertainty over the details
and dates pertaining to the life of
Masashi.
What follows is based
primarily on his own account,
as recorded in the book of five rings,
me and massage Masashi was
born in the spring of 15,
84 in the village of Mia
Moto in the Yoshino districts
of the Masaka province in
Japan.
He was born into an ability with his
mother who died giving birth to him being
the daughter of a minor local chief Tang.
His father Mooney was a warrior in the
Shin Man Clan who had become an experts
in the fighting arts.
He was especially adept at Jujitsu
swordsmanship and the use of the guitar.
An iron rod with forklift protrusions
when he was in his thirties.
Mooney had been invited to the capital
of Kyoto to deal with another highly
regarded warrior in the presence of the
Shogun Mooney beat the man in two out of
three bouts.
The victory established and massage
his father as he whole show,
which means without equal in Japan,
really was intense on teaching his
son everything that he knew about the
fighting arts.
Although Misashi it was a quick learner.
He had a stubborn streak that sort of
constantly clashing with his father.
While everyone else treated me with
the utmost respect and reverence,
Misashi would often talk back
and criticize his father.
This resulted in a volatile relationship
which often culminated in violence.
On one occasion,
Muni took a knife and threw it at his
son was actually managed to dodge the
weapon,
which buried itself in
the wall beside him,
but the fathers aren't
get it was not over.
He,
through the seven year
old boy out of the house,
essentially disowning
him was actually crossed,
become a soccer pass to the province of
Hiroshima where he traveled to the small
village of [inaudible].
Here he was taken in by his uncle,
dearin.
Dearin has once been a warrior,
but he had long ago
renounced the fighting arts,
becoming a Buddhist monk and is
living a life of study and meditation.
He raised Misashi at is
small Buddhist temples,
sat on the edge of the village here,
the coin lands to read and to write
as well as to meditate and develop the
spirituality,
massaging his real passion.
However,
lay with a martial arts.
He spends countless
hours alone in the woods,
sparring against the unforgiving
trunks of pine trees.
His anger at his being released as he
builds upon the skills that had been
instilled by that great worry out
and his work for book of five rings.
Misashi recorded that his first real fight
occurred when he was 13 years of age.
He related that to passing warrior
by the name of Mickey High.
I put a sign up along the Ohio River,
challenging any local swordsman to a deal.
The bolds and impetus Misashi
took up the challenge,
writing his name on the sign,
key high,
considered the challenge and joke,
but accepted any way intent on teaching
the young upstart or lesson ms dot
Ashley's Uncle Doren with sharks.
When he heard what his nephew had
done on the day of the challenge,
she went to head of the
buyer and attempted to beg
us off while he was eating
with key high misashi challenged his
opponents with a six foot quarter staff.
He caught off guard,
clubbing him to the ground,
and then striking him between the
eyes with a succession of blows.
He then beat him to death.
Three years later,
Masashi left Heroku and set off
to make his way in the world.
He traveled along the sand Yoda,
the old high road scouting the northern
shore of the inland sea to the streets
of Shem on Saqib.
From that,
he ferried across the waters to the port
of [inaudible] and then onto knack at
Psu.
This was the castle town,
whereas father now lives moody had
entered into the service of the master of
Nicodemus,
you causal.
The teenager arrived to
find his father's on me.
We're in the midst of a campaign,
just,
uh,
do the islands of shoe and wage war
on the western provinces was actually,
was recruited into the force and soon
found himself fighting alongside his
father.
It was his first taste of war.
The campaign proved to be a great success
with two provinces being brought onto
the dominion of your Shitaka.
Following the campaign with Sashi,
his aging father retired from active
duty moving to the nearby port of kids.
Suki.
Yes,
as the father exited from the wells of
mortal Kombat of a sudden it was just
getting started.
That campaign,
it had wet his appetite and he was eager
for more in terms of becoming a great
warrior or swordsmen like his father.
He set out a path forward.
He needed to perfect the
art of swordsmanship,
seek out and defeat other masters and
then found his own school of swordsman
ship.
Never one to think small.
Misashi had set his sights on the most
prestigious school of swordsmanship in
the realm the famous
Yoshioka clowning in Kyoto.
He knew that if he could fully
defeat even one member of this plan,
he would put himself on the fast track
to recognition as a master swordsman,
so without saying a word to his father,
he rose early one morning,
collected his few belongings and
set out to claim his destiny.
He bought it his way onto a small
merchant vessel to the port of Sakaki.
From there,
he sat on foot ticket Jojo and
sought out the Yoshioka can.
He threw down his challenge,
which was easily accepted
by their top swordsman.
St Jerome.
The jewel would take place
on the grounds of the temple.
What do you really have to the venue?
Masashi leapt upon his
opponent without wanting,
just as he had done in his first deal
and felled see jerry with a single blow
from his October.
The fight was over before
it had even properly began.
The shock defeat of their top
swordsmen rocked the Yoshioka clan,
so Jira is brother denture.
Chiro was incensed that the manner in
which the young upstart from the south had
attacked his brother
when he was unprepared.
He challenged him it to a second challenge
on the very spot where the first it
occurred.
This time there was the Yoshioka
swordsmen who charged first attempting to
strike a fatal blow with
this five foot Bako massage.
She managed to wrestle the
weapon away from denture cheery,
using it to beat his opponent to death.
The Yoshioka had now been best
dish twice in short order,
and this was too much
for that honor to bath.
They decided that
Misashi had to be killed.
They devised a plan to ambush him in
the woods outside of the hostel where he
was staying more than 100 Yoshioka
students armed with sticks,
bows and arrows gathered under
the leadership of denture.
His son,
his name was Matt Cheerio,
and he came up against
Misashi unperturbed.
Masashi rushed,
straightforward matter,
Shakira,
killing him in front of the others.
Overall,
the Yoshioka fell back,
allowing Misashi to slip away,
having established his supremacy blank,
decimating the most highly
respected warrior clan in the land.
Misashi returns to Kyoto
in the space of a few days.
He had brought down a school
of swordsmanship that had
reigned supreme for over
a century still.
He knew that he had a lot to learn in
order to become the greatest warrior in
the nation from Kyoto.
He traveled to the temple of Nahrep.
Here he founds a line of warrior monks
who were experts in the art of fighting
with the of the temple master
was fascinated with massage.
She's ability to find
with two swords at once.
Kinda test is find a student
against the newcomer.
He arranged for two belts
with a monk named aqua zone.
In neither of these fights was the lawns
are able to gain the upper hand over
Masashi leaving,
Nara and the south.
He traveled to each city that was
teeming with accomplished swordsmen.
Many of these swordsmen had forged that
talents on the field of battle here.
Masashi opened his own Dojo,
one of hundreds in the city news,
quickly spread of his unique style and
he soon was being flooded with students.
One of them was Mazuma cuts scenario,
well respected and
battle hardened warrior.
The fame of massages Dojo.
It's spread reaching all the way to
ido castle and the shogun himself.
He was invited to teach that,
but declines when he realized that he
would be subject to a member if he hated
Yag.
You can after teaching
an ido for seven years,
but it's actually decided
to return to could Suki,
the town of his father.
The aging Mooney had set up his own Dojo
and was eager to pass it on to his son
before he arrived back in.
Could Suki,
however Musashi wants to fight one
more challenge at his journey home,
brought him to the small islands of fun,
Ashima in the streets of Shamona.
Second,
it was here that he was challenged by a
famed warrior by the name of [inaudible]
Congero.
This was a man so fierce
that he understands the
Monica Demon of the western
provinces.
He was a master [inaudible].
The greatest Japanese sword.
Legend tells us that massage,
she's only weapon,
was a bucket or a wooden sword that he
had carved from an owner of the boat that
had brought him to the islands.
With this,
he managed to subdue and kills the Saki.
We don't immediately jumped into his
boat and rode out to see in order to get
away from Susaki is enraged followers.
Misashi now completed his journey to
Suku where he began teaching at his
father's Dojo for three years.
He lived in,
worked in a small seaside village.
During this time,
his fractured relationship with his
father had got my better with the old man
criticizing his son's marsh
inability at every opportunity.
When Mooney died at the age of 85,
Masashi was more relieved than saddened.
Shortly after his father's passing,
Misashi received a letter
from his former students,
Missou new cut scenario.
War had broken out between the grades.
Clans have Tagawa,
arends,
Toya,
Tony got scenario was about to
take pause in the seed zone,
the Tokugawa site,
along with his eldest son,
who was just 16 years old.
Cotsen already requested the Musashi
serve as part of a special escort of 10
mounted warriors for his son.
The 30 year olds Misashi Solvis as his
opportunity to jump back into the thick
of combat.
He sets off from Turkey
to the port of Sakaki.
He was determined to be the protector in
battle of the young son if his beloved
students,
he met up with [inaudible] forces
writing at the head of 4,000 men as they
advanced on a soccer and
then on to Kakadu or hamlet.
It's made up of a few farms stretching
along the southern bank of the Yamamoto
River just a few miles down stream.
A lodge enemy force had
gathered that night.
However,
cats scenarios,
Ami managed to surrounds
the Toyotomi forces.
The attack was ordered at 10:00 PM.
The hour of the snake and the
Toyotomi were sent reeling.
They fled across the river.
I will need to be chased
down by cat scenarios.
Men Misashi was in the lead
wielding his favorite weapon.
The bulk tall records tell us that he
stood on the heights of a bridge sending
one enemy warrior after another,
flying with the deadly blows of his
trusted blocked all the Osaka Windsor in
summer campaigns in which
the Tokugawa were victorious,
but an ends to the resistance
of Japan's western warlords.
The culmination of the hostilities
was the siege of a soccer castle.
It was the largest vessel in which
Masashi would ever take part with many
thousands of worry is being
slaughtered on both sides.
Among those of his comrades
to fall was Naca Galwass.
She amount of keep.
It was stricken down.
His men had stormed the
southern gate of the castle.
The man had three sons who
traveled with the army.
The two older boys took part in the siege,
but the youngest was just 11
with the death of his father.
The young man now needed a guardian
massaging,
took the boy Minuka Suki under his wing,
adopting him as his son and set
off with the castle town of him a.
from there,
they want zero.
Who were his stepmother,
lived for the next two years.
He lived here caring for
his elderly stepmother while
also providing for his new
son many hours each day with spence
imparting to nick and a Suki,
the fighting skills that he himself
had learned as a young boy from his own
father.
This tranquil existence was interrupted
when news reached the village of heroes
that Akita mood some Masa,
the current Lord of him.
A castle was going to move.
The new Lord was going to be a Honda.
Tomasa.
Masa Masashi saw this change in leadership
as an opportunity for his adopted son
during the storming,
a soccer castle Tadamasa had been in
command if the second eastern phonics
directly behind the troops of cap
scenario where Masashi with stations.
He has therefore seen Musashi
and action in the heat of battle.
Ms Dot Aldrete requested that his son,
mid Masa be given duty
in the Lord's household,
not that Masa agreed as the boy was
made a page to his own son to Tokyo.
At the same time,
Sasha was hired by the
neighboring demio August Sowell,
Tarzan,
yet he was appointed as an advisor
to the magistrate in charge of the
construction of a huge building projects
the construction of the Kashi Castle.
This was followed by the
planning of the town,
if it may.
Misashi was also in charge of the castle
gardens and oversaw the construction of
a tea house miniature
mountains into miniature lake.
He proved to have a meticulous eye for
detail and was obsessive in getting every
tree shrub and stone placed just right.
The years that he spent to Kashi
were the happiest of massages,
life,
as well as planning out the
landscaping and tending to the gardens.
He instructed his retainers in the
art of fighting with two swords.
He also enjoyed hearing of these successes
of his son who grew in favor in the
house of Tata Masa.
In the spring of [inaudible] 16,
26 loads had a Tokyo was struck down
with tuberculosis being forced to keep us
quarters that he may castle after a
three month struggle with a disease.
He died at 1:30.
We're so actually knew all too well
what this meant for his son as the key
retainer.
If the stricken Lord Makinos Suki was
customarily bounced to commit ritual
suicide by December ailments,
Makina Suki is death left,
a deep emotional scar on Masashi from
which he would never fully recover for
months.
He shunned or company retreating to the
forest to commune with nature and tried
to come to terms with his great loss
almost exactly a year after Makina souk is
deaf massage.
She adopted a second son,
a boy named Laurie,
who was the second son of tomorrow,
is a Mitsui,
a Samurai,
and the service of the
Lord of Mickey Castle.
When their costs had been
overthrown by the Tagawa army,
hit some.
Mitsui took up the life of a poor farmer.
When he died,
his youngest son,
Lori,
became an orphan.
Masashi took it in and arranged for him
to enter the service of Lord Tanzania.
The boy would eventually attained
the rank of senior retainer stations,
only southern islands of can you shoe
Misashi moved to be closer to the boy and
spent the last 20 years of
his life on the islands.
Miss Ashley built a large Dojo on the
islands and soon had a huge following,
all eager to learn from the great master,
even though located on a remote islands,
far from the main centers.
Many martial arts masters visited his
Dojo to experience the art of fighting
with two swords.
The aging the associate was respected
and admired as a great martial arts
grandmaster still,
he was,
as he had always been an outsider.
He did not agree with
himself as was expected.
He left his hair grow long and unkempt.
He also sell them bathed and refused
to wear the traditional attire of a
swordsman.
Of that time,
in his waning years,
even abandoned his two swords,
preferring to carry and using nothing
more than a five foot wooden staff in
early at 16,
38 and armed revolt broke
out in the province of.
He's in the rebellion was made up of
Christians led by 17 year old Ama Coosa
Shiro.
They numbered more than 20,000
men that has gone to themselves.
The long abandoned hardcastle Lord is
how does the employer have massage.
She's adopted.
Son engaged the aging master to escort
his 23 year old son to the battlefields
along with 8,000 men,
Misashi state at the boys' side,
throughout the entire siege
when the defenders in selling,
because all three boulders
down from the walls,
he leapt in front of the Lord source
and fended them off with his staff.
Misashi hadn't been back
from the rebellion for long
when he was approaching,
take up a position in the household of
the Dynamo of one of the largest fiefs in
the country.
This was Hosokawa Tata,
Toshi.
He wanted Misashi to relocate,
to come emoto and instruct his retainers
in the art of fighting with two sorts.
This ultimate accepted,
arriving and Kumomoto in September of 16,
40,
he was given a comfortable mentioned
on the northeastern side of the castle
grounds.
Massage,
took to spending much time
in the mountains of it
washow where he would while
away the hours in meditation
and contemplation,
he found a cave which
afforded him perfect solitude.
It was here that he began to put his
thoughts to paper in the early spring of
16,
45.
He completed the first draft of the
work that would make him a mortal down
through the ages,
the Gorran no show or book of five rings.
The book had taken five
seasons to complete each one
and seeing the completion
of one long scroll.
He named them for scrolls of earth,
fire,
water,
wind,
and heaven.
Shortly after the completion
of his great work massage,
she's health took a turn for the worse.
Within a month,
he was no longer able to teach.
He withdrew to his house
outside the castle walls.
Feeling is life adding a way.
He summoned his chief retainer
and handed in the garden,
no show.
Having passed on his legacy,
he then closed his eyes and allowed
the life to drain from his body.
It was June the 13th,
16,
40th five,
shortly after his death,
a stone memorial to be known as mounds
Masashi was directed not far from his
home and Keto for centuries thereafter,
passes by with dismounted from their
horses to pay homage to the greatest
swordsmen that Japan which effort produce.
So I really hope you found
this video interesting.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button
below and do not forget to subscribe for
brand new videos just like
this every Monday and Thursday.
Also check out some of our videos from
the archive that over there on the right.
If you enjoyed this video,
you'll enjoy some of those and as always,
thank you for watching.